[Applause]
from Hollywood it's Michael bubleman on
Dancing With the Stars
start to play it was all about Canadian
crooner Michael Buble on last night's
episode of Dancing With the Stars on
Disney plus people that know me realize
that my ego didn't need that but I mean
are you kidding me and my whole country
tonight I hope was watching on Disney
plus I hope I made you proud
and what about his judging skills I just
think these judges are full of it
I love judging people because I'm a
judgy kind of person why are you so good
at everything dude like everything you
[Applause]
need people Brave and Valiant especially
when they don't have a background in
dance effortless mesmerizing and
expressively erotic that was so
beautiful but what did Charlie and the
cast think of having Michael join them
this week he's incredible just during
rehearsal like he's singing so
nonchalantly it's insane he's so
talented and it was it was really cool
to watch him in person I'm a big fan of
Michael Buble it grew up listening to
him he's probably just watching the vibe
like watching if I was doing that in a
club or something like that's the kind
of Judge I need I love Michael to death
and it was just nothing but love tonight
and when it comes to summing up his
whole night
it meant so much to me genuinely that I
got to be part of it and they use my
music
[Applause]
[Music]
no points where I was emotional but I
didn't want to be too cringy because I
want to look sexy but it was really
emotional for me it was a really
beautiful night
[Applause]